so
scam financial scam story number one
is trump said he would be donating his
presidential salary washington post can
find no evidence that the last six
months of his salary were actually
donated
the next piece of the financial scam
is that it is now believed donald trump
moved donated money money donated to
fight the unfair election results
to his own businesses
according to new filings check out this
article by greg graziosi
which says donald trump moved more than
200 uh that i guess it's supposed to be
200 000 20 200 000
uh dollars donated to his make america
great again pack into his own private
business accounts according to an
analysis of his federal filings the
money was moved in february a month
after trump left office money donated to
pax is meant to be spent solely on
campaign efforts
forbes reports that the former president
also set up a leadership pac
generally used to support other
candidates that's the pack where he said
i will tell you who the good republicans
are
donate to me
and i'll distribute the money as i see
fit
trump took 30 million dollars from his
make america great again pack and moved
it to the new pack called save america
that pack eventually grew to 90 million
dollars and trump took an additional 79
000 out of that pack for his own uses
trump's business the trump org regularly
interacted with his campaign pacs in one
instance the trump org charged his
campaign pack 38 000 to rent in rent via
trump tower commercial llc of which
trump is 100 owner during 2016 trump ran
his campaign out of the skyscraper but
his 2020 campaign was partially run from
dc despite this the trump organization
continued to collect rent for trump
tower
in total the trump organization
collected 188 000 in rent between
january and june all paid through
trump's campaign donations trump
restaurants also collected rent from the
pack even after the former president
left office and during a time when
tourists visiting trump tower were few
due to the coronavirus pandemic totaling
15 thousand dollars and it just goes on
and on save america the leadership pack
paid trump hotel collection 79 000 after
trump was out of office
uh expenses largely for lodging and
meals the trump organization did not
comment on the self-dealing payments but
the former president did issue a
statement boasting that his affiliated
committees have approximately 100
million dollars of cash ready for use
the statement said these fundraising
numbers coupled with tremendous support
in so many other ways show that
president trump supporters want him to
continue to fight
um we
we knew that the pac save america pac we
we knew the entire donate so that we can
fight the election results we told you
it was a grift back in
december
january february if you looked at the
fine print when they were sending out
the fundraising emails it would say
we can use up to what up to 50 cents of
every dollar donated
to pay off campaign debts for example
um this is really it's almost like a
political version of the producers and i
still go back to the idea that trump's
entire 2016 primary run
was
really just a way to make money and get
publicity and become more more
well-known and then monetize it after
losing the republican primary or
certainly after losing the election
but trump overestimated apparently the
intelligence of his own electorate of
the republican party electorate and when
you do that weird things can happen and
the weird thing that happened was that
the republican electorate was actually
ignorant enough and radical enough to
vote trump to be their nominee
um and his followers still to this day
belief he was draining the swamp or
whatever it was so again it's just like
with trump's salary this amount of money
should really be meaningless to trump
like 79 grand into the trump tower
restaurants and uh 20 grand or a hundred
grand or 188 in rent these are amounts
of money that should be meaningless to a
guy like trump who even by the
conservative estimates has two billion
dollars
um
but this is it's greedy
cheap and narcissistic and what will his
followers say probably nothing that's
the reality if you won't go to his
followers um they they will say listen
this this is a guy with why would he go
to some crappy restaurant when he has
his own restaurants where he can hold
campaign events why would he rent some
office when he owns so much real estate
it makes sense that he would do this
they will defend him
to the last day
it was a grift from day one and the
financial documents seem to support it
will there be consequences for
self-dealing probably not probably not
but
it is certainly the type of thing where
if it were democrats doing this
it would be 24 7 on fox news it's not
even a story on right-wing media though
one of our sponsors is rise the
science-based app that makes it easy to
improve your sleep and daily energy
i have struggled with sleep at times in
my life i've tried many different things
and rise has been really useful
it tracks your sleep debt which is how
much sleep you essentially owe your body
tracks your general rhythms helps you
understand your daytime energy levels
and rise can improve your sleep and
energy by giving you personalized
feedback about your sleep metrics when
you should go to bed when you should
wake up in terms of optimizing your
personal rest it can even tell you
things like how long should you expect
to be groggy in the morning based on
when you wake up you can make
science-based improvements to 16
different habits that will make you feel
more rested every day and most rise
users start feeling that way in the
first five days including me and ryze is
still helping me every day it's great
it's based on real sleep science
very few things are as important as
improving your sleep go to
risescience.com
pacman to try rise free for a week the
link is underneath this video